clean code and JavaScript variables I'm
going to be sharing some guidelines to
make sure your variables are readable
reusable and refactor Abul the first
thing is to use meaningful and
pronounceable variable names you can see
in this example VAR YY YY mmm SDS TR
equals moment format so and so on
instead of calling it why why why why mm
s d TR just call it
year-month-day so this variables a lot
more meaningful and you can easily
pronounce it the next thing is use es6
constants when variable values do not
change we have var first us present
equals George Washington instead of
using var you should use Const because
the first US president is always going
to be George Washington the next thing
is use the same vocabulary for the same
type of variable if you have three
different functions or variables we have
get user info get client data get
customer record let's say these are in
different parts of your program well
it's all basically the same thing a
client can be considered a user a
customer can be considered a user you
should call these the same thing and
each project program so we're just gonna
get rid of those two and we're gonna
make this just get user get user you
don't have to say get info data what we
know it's gonna be data so we just call
them get user in every part of your
program so it's easier to remember what
you use the next thing I want to talk to
you about is use searchable names so if
you look at this function or this for
loop for VAR I equals 0 I is less than
525,600 well so what is this number here
what does that number mean it's actually
better to put it right in your program
what that number means the truth is we
will read more code than we will ever
write so it's important that the code we
do write is readable and searchable so
we're gonna declare what this variable
means in a capitalized VAR globe so
we're gonna put
and then we can just change this to now
it's a lot more obvious what what that
supposed to be in the program and as an
added benefit of it being more readable
it's also more searchable if you want to
search for that number in the program if
you can just search for the name of the
variable next thing I want to talk about
is to use explanatory variables so if
you see this Const city state reg X and
then this whole regex thing and then the
safe city state city city state reg X
dot match city state reg X and you just
look at all this whole thing so there's
a way to make this a little more
readable because so what is this thing
right here and what is this thing what
if we could just make this into a
variable let's just work backwards I
want this to be City and I want this to
be state now we have to go and fill
these in so we're going to do so you can
see it's doing the same thing except
it's just breaking it down a little more
so it's more obvious what's happening
first we're trying to find the the match
and then we break it apart into city and
state and then when we call the function
it's more obvious what we're passing
into the function okay next up is don't
add unneeded context so if we look at
this whole thing VAR car equals car
making a car model Accord car color blue
and we call the function function paint
car car car car color equals red so look
at this part right here car dot car
color so we have a repetition we have
car and we have car again right here at
car color so when you are storing the
car make don't call it car mate
just call me because we already have car
right here and then for a model just
call it model car color just call it
color and then down here you can just
call car color and then you want it to
repeat yourself just under your context
let's
go down a little bit more now the last
one imma talk about is short-circuiting
is cleaner than conditionals so let's
look at the bad example first the
function create microbrewery name bought
a brewery name if name the embroidery
name equals name else brewery name
equals hipster brew company there's a
way to make this a lot quicker if we can
just take this whole thing out and make
this into a conditional and that's it so
this whole thing was this conditional
here was the same as that whole thing
before so it's a lot cleaner it does the
exact same thing and it's easier to read
it's easier to understand well thanks
for watching my name is beau Carnes if
you check the description you can see a
link to what inspired this video don't
forget to subscribe
and remember use your code for good